Los Angeles Mayor Eric Garcetti has a
plan that he says will help solve racism
in America well it requires cutting up
to a hundred and fifty million dollars
from the police budget in putting it
toward more social welfare and jobs
programs and black communities
now Garcetti also said that failure to
enact his Grand Designs would mean quote
we're going to continue being the
killers that we are my next guest Jamie
McBride director of the Los Angeles
Police Protective League is just irate
about that the nation is wrong mr
McBride joins me now Jamie mayor
Garcetti said you were taking his
remarks out of context and that by
killers he meant our collective burden
on society whatever the heck that means
so what's your what's your further
response to his explanation I think it's
quite clear what he meant because he
actually corrected it said he didn't
mean LAPD men
officers across the nation which i think
is even worse you know Eric Garcetti has
security detail on his residence to
guard his family 24/7 his children so he
has killers gardening his children
that's not ridiculous this thing is know
we have officers that were injured the
last week and a half one was shot we had
officers that we had their heads
fracture the skulls fractured they're in
the hospital and one minute literally
he's praising us for our dedication and
service two days later he's calling us
killers and there's something definitely
wrong with Eric Garcetti he has failed
the leadership test
he is definitely unstable and and I
think he needs to step back into a self
reflect because he just can't handle the
stress of of a big city like Los Angeles
well he's focused on chasing people off
beaches apparently that's
easier Duty for him here's what
congresswoman Karen bass wants to do
with the money
Jamie that would be cut under this plan
from the police budget watch part of
that cry is a desire for there to be
significant higher investment in
communities looking at why police are
needed what happens what are the root
causes of the problems in communities
and a lot of people feel when it comes
to the defense budget maybe that money
could be used in different ways
Jamie sounds reasonable you know for one
thing you can't cut the police budget
there's too many things that are not
going to happen the riots that we
experienced the last two weeks that's
gonna be an every day occurrence it's
gonna be like a Kurt Russell movie
escape from Los Angeles you know you're
you're if you cut the budget you have a
slower response time to respond sir 911
calls because you can have fewer
officers on the streets if you have if
you cut the budget you're gonna have a
slower investigative investigations talk
about reform we're the number one agency
when it comes to reform well part of
being reformed it's gonna have training
and we're to have training we have to
have a budget to make sure that we're
within the the reforming that they want
us to be in and listen this is all a
little bit step further in Laura let's
look a couple years ahead now he wants
to cut the budget what's coming around
the corner for Los Angeles the world cup
and beyond that the Olympics now in
1980-81 dad a mass hiring for police
officers gearing up for the 83 Olympics
if he's cuts the budget we're gonna be
so far behind I don't think it would be
safe to have the World Cup here I don't
think it'd be safe to have the Olympics
here I remember the 84 Olympics I was
there in California that summer that was
that was fun
but all I can say is given what I saw in
the footage in Santa Monica that the
mainstream networks didn't play if you
miss that footage of what was being done
to those businesses and those incredible
people of all backgrounds search around
you have to be your own investigative
reporter to find it but Jamie we're
gonna follow this keep in touch with us
please
we're supporters of the police and I
know you guys have a very diverse police
force as well so thank you so much